the crime scene I've seen the police
I've seen the yellow tape
now on good day waking up after tragedy
the latest on the deadly strip mass
stabbing what we learned overnight about
the suspect
plus holiday hiring already in full
effect what won massive e-commerce
company is offering is incentive to new
workers plus she's sweet sassy and she's
joining us in the studio right now hot
chocolate talking all things Pride here
on Good Day Las Vegas stay tuned
now this is good day Las Vegas live
local now six o'clock good morning to
you here on this Friday morning we do
have team coverage of the deadly mass
stabbing on the Strip but before we get
to that continuing coverage let's get
you out the door on the road safely
Sherry it's a busy weekend we need some
good weather super busy weekend and it's
been a warm October week that's for sure
temperatures staying above normal we
were back into those low 90s yesterday
gorgeous shot looking out through the
High Roller off to the east where we see
some early light and you can tell we've
got clear skies out there more
neighborhoods cooling off to the 60s
that's more fall-like isn't it we get
these mornings in the 60s it feels good
so longer nights allow us to cool down
more we've got humidity between 25 and
30 percent and dew points in the 30s so
we've been cooling off more and drying
out more in the mornings 80 degrees by
mid-morning will be on our way to some
nice warm mid 80s by noon sunscreen
don't forget it we still have a UV index
of six in the half afternoon so if
you're Outdoors for a while you might
start to get a little pink if you're not
protecting your skin 85 the normal high
we're looking for low 90s and some light
Northeast breezes for your Friday we'll
see if the weekend brings any changes
and what about next week things have
already changed since yesterday's
forecast let's get to the roads good
morning Nate well the only thing
changing here is more cars getting out
onto the road South 15 you're getting
busy now around Sahara there are a
couple of cars off on the shoulder so
that could be a lot worse in the
meantime you still have some Lane
restrictions because of the ndot I-15
Tropicana project you know over the next
couple of years it's getting really ugly
there as they tear down Tropicana for
now it is just these cones and the lane
restrictions that I hope you're getting
used to so far not a huge delay there
coming up on our next report we're going
to head on down to Las Vegas pull over
into Spring Mountain which of course was
closed as police investigated that
incident yesterday that will be coming
up in our next report Heather
[Music]
it's crazy that happened on the Strip
where it's like a lot of tourists and
stuff it could have been anybody
interested someone like
so violent
this morning locals and tourists alike
waking up with questions about safety
following yesterday's deadly and
unprovoked stabbing attack roads are
back open this morning as you heard from
Nate this investigation continues we've
got all the angles covered our Candace
Charles standing by with more about the
man accused first let's start with what
we know just before noon a man wielding
a knife on a sidewalk in front of the
wind began stabbing people at random
Metro says the stabbing was unprovoked
two people died another six were injured
Witnesses say one of the victims was a
woman dressed as a show girl and the
whole attack they say happened very
quickly at the center of this case
though all the families now devastated
by loss as we learn more about these
victims killed both of them from Las
Vegas the coroner says 47 year old Brent
Hallett and 30 year old maristi Giovanni
were both killed they haven't released
any other details about those two
individuals at this time as far as the
other victims two are recovering at
Sunrise Hospital they're expected to
survive the others at UMC and one this
morning still listed in critical
condition we are learning more about the
suspect this morning this man here
behind me Yani Barrios now Behind Bars
Candace Charles joins us live now from
the strip with more on what we've
learned about him and Candace first tell
us what's going on in this trip what's
the mood like there this morning
well you know the strip really never
sleeps Heather but people are finally
getting up and starting to walk around a
lot of people looking and seeing extra
police on the Strip here today and
wondering really what's going on
unfortunately say 32 year old Johnny
Berrios started stabbing people in front
of the wind he's up eight people two of
those people unfortunately died some
they were also from Las Vegas the
security on the Strip has been on high
alert as everyone else now this is
surveillance video of him running from
the scene police say burials use a large
knife to stop the victims again both of
those who died are from Las Vegas for
visitors some who just arrived yesterday
they say it's a shock and such a lively
destination but are happy that police
acted quickly
hey we're safe here but uh I hope this
will never happen again and I I see the
place that's safe is now there are so
many police here so we're like you're
live here
the Bears is being held in jail and is
facing multiple charges including two
counts of open murder as well as six six
counts of attempted murder he's
scheduled to appear in court later today
now what caused this incident right now
we do not know it's unprovoked attack
and of course as we learn more details
will bring them with to you so stick
with us right here on air online and on
social for the latest for now live from
Las Vegas strip I'm Candace Charles 8
News Now in court there for his first
appearance today Candace thank you
although this was an isolated incident
violence on the Strip has been a growing
concern in fact there was an arrest made
after a stabbing just last month outside
Caesar's Palace the injuries though in
that case were not serious back in
August a man shot and killed a family
member at the Mirage hotel inside a room
there two women were also injured in
that shooting in March a Taurus was
stabbed to death on the pedestrian
bridge between New York New York and the
MGM Grand this prompted County
Commissioners to redefine the bridge as
a crosswalk in order to prevent
loitering last year we spoke with the
current head of the homicide unit and he
said at the time they were experiencing
unprecedented crime around the strip
Captain Dory Koren said repeat offenders
visiting Las Vegas could certainly be a
factor and it needs to be addressed by
our legal system there is a proposal in
the works that could soon be implemented
around the city of Las Vegas and in the
corridor we first told you about the
order out Corridor in August it aims to
keep anyone convicted of a crime in the
strip Corridor out some locals are
behind it saying they do want to feel
more safe in their Hometown again the
ordinance passed in early August it
states those convicted can be banned
from the area up to a year though no
word yet on when that ordinance will
take effect there is also a similar
proposal in the works for the downtown
area from the city of Las Vegas of
course authorities are continuing to
reassure the community that there is no
larger threat Sheriff Joe Lombardo even
praising Metro's response to the
incident
I'm very proud of lvnpd and our ability
to be eyes on and physically on to take
this suspect into custody in a matter of
minutes from the prime the crime being
committed
at this time no word yet on how violent
acts like this might impact upcoming
events on the Strip or downtown and that
does include Las Vegas's Annual Pride
Parade that's happening this weekend I
also don't know if it'll have a wider
reach to events like our City's annual
New Year's celebrations of course bring
you any updates here on air and online
at 8newsnow.com
some other news to get to here at 608
we're also learning more about another
murder that happened near Mandalay Bay
this one on Las Vegas Boulevard between
Hacienda and Russell Monday night Metro
Police say 27-year-old Malik price hit
Christopher David in the back of the
head with a brick killing him according
to a police report price told police he
did it in Cold Blood he's scheduled to
be in court on Monday Nate now to some
of that other news in North Las Vegas
Police looking for this missing man he's
51-year-old Daniel random last seen
leaving his home near Centennial Parkway
in Aviary way on Wednesday night so he
has short-term memory loss from a
previous brain injury he's 6-1 as the
name Isabel tattooed on the left side of
his neck if you've seen him please call
North Las Vegas Police to the animal
foundation dog adoptions well they're on
hold again this following the spread of
a serious virus so the adoption had been
stopped earlier this week briefly
resuming for a day before this most
recent stoppage bottom line seven dogs
have tested positive for canine
pneumovirus 30 more are showing symptoms
the animal foundation says all the dogs
getting treatment are responding well
but they're still not sure when
adoptions are going to start up again
now you say you lose your dog it ends up
the animal foundation you'll still be
able to get down there and pick up your
dog
absolutely yeah okay well a quick
reminder the Raiders are taking on the
Kansas City Chiefs in Kansas City Monday
night but you can see the game right
here on Channel 8 with kickoff set for 5
p.m this is your home for the most
Raiders games Raiders and Chiefs right
here on Channel 8 Monday at 5 p.m tune
in don't miss it coming up later we're
giving away tickets to see Donny Osmond
right here in Las Vegas you'll have your
chance to win four tickets to the show a
VIP experience plus a 200 gift dollar
gift card to Ruth's Chris Steakhouse oh
my goodness dinner ah and dreamy Donnie
stop it's too much caller number eight
will win we'll put that number up for
you when it's time to call in just a
little bit Heather yeah good prize all
right regardless of what Sherry's
telling us with the weather Fall is here
those decorations are going up and well
unfortunately so are the prices so if
you're looking for the perfect pumpkin
to pick be prepared to Pony up
Sherry looks like you have a visitor
over there well you know what Heather
it's hot chocolate kind of weather yes
it doesn't feel like it does it but
you are year-round weather thank you yes
you are oh my goodness hot chocolate is
with us would you like to help me do the
forecast for Friday my dear starting at
76 at 8 A.M 8 A.M that's right it's 12
p.m 85 3 P.M 91 uh 6 p.m 89 and 8 P.M
86. I'm seeing rainbows and sunshine
today what do you think
we're going to talk with hot chocolate
coming up we are gearing up for Pride
week and weekend and joining us is hot
chocolate we're going to find out what's
in store for the pride parade downtown
so excited oh I can't wait it's gonna be
fabulous oh my goodness you've been here
a few years and we're just going to talk
more about you and pride week and all
the fun stuff coming up in just a few
minutes and eight news now we'll be
right back
foreign
hair Breast Care and Southwest Medical
live
this is good day Las Vegas
now time is 6 14. President Biden says
he'll pardon people convicted federally
for possessing marijuana president
making that announcement yesterday the
pardon applies to anyone convicted of a
single simple possession between 1992
and 2021. the White House is estimating
about 6 500 Americans had prior
possession convictions here in Nevada
state officials voted to allow pardons
for thousands of low-level marijuana
offenders in June of 2020 and that rule
applies to any offender caught with an
ounce or less Nate all right let's talk
about getting your pumpkin on well
surprise if you haven't gotten it yet it
is going to cost you a little bit extra
like about 10 percent more for now now
the folks at pumpkin patches have a tip
to make sure you're getting the freshest
pumpkin you can get look at the stem if
it's colorful then you've got a fresh
pumpkin if the stem is starting to turn
white you're looking at a pretty old
pumpkin Sherry oh that's a good tip I
didn't realize that Nate thank you a
touch of Disney Magic is coming to the
valley Walt Disney Animation Studios
announced that it will team up with
Lighthouse immersive Studios those are
the folks behind immersive Van Gogh
maybe you've seen that show together
they'll create an immersive experience
that will debut inside the art space at
Crystals next year it's said to make
audiences feel that they've entered the
Incredible World of Disney characters
and become one with them ticket pricing
and the on sale date will be announced
at a future date but it looks magical it
really does well we've got a magical
forecast for you as well a lot of folks
are just loving this warm October
weather look at these beautifully clear
skies as we look out across the North
Valley there so pretty there's downtown
Las Vegas going to be hopping tonight
we've got first Friday we've got the
pride parade and there's so much going
on again in Las Vegas you got the
Renaissance Festival out at Sunset Park
this weekend it is going to be a busy
weekend and October is always busy for
us because our weather cools off a
little bit and we usually have great
weather to be out and about for all the
festivals and the fun we do have some
60s around the fringes of the valley
70's in the interior Valley outside the
valley it's been cool up in Indian
Springs and 58 degrees 47 in Caliente
Northeast Clark County Mesquite at 67
low 70's for Boulder City Laughlin at 77
and Pahrump you're in the mid 60s look
at Death Valley still 81 with 40s up in
Reno low 50s for Tonopah Ely coming in
at 36. we're going to aim for another
extra warm day we were at 91 yesterday
that's right where we'll be again today
mid 80s is normal Sunrise officially 6
41 in sunset at 6 16. the Northwest
still under high pressure in fact it
goes all the way from the Pacific
Northwest down to the Southwest we will
get a system finally coming in early
next week that will break down the extra
warmth and it looked like was going to
bring us a lot of wind and cooler
temperatures next week but I don't think
the effects are going to be quite as
dramatic there's been a huge cold front
though that's dropped through the
Northern Plains the Upper Midwest if
you're traveling say to Minneapolis
Chicago Kansas City take a nice warm
coat because they're looking at highs
only in the 50s Mornings in the 30s the
southeast looks nice and of course so
much recovery and work going on in
Florida since the hurricane last week
but the weather looks like it will be
very quiet and sunny there is low
pressure that's still spinning showers
and thunderstorms into New Mexico and of
course it's the big balloon fiesta in
Albuquerque they've been dodging showers
and thunderstorms all week and for us
we'll stay under this Dome of high
pressure 60 degrees up on the mountain
and then next week we're looking at a
chance of rain in the mountains and
maybe even a little high elevation snow
we'll see how that goes 91 for the
valley today normal high as I said 85
light northeasterly breezes temperatures
don't change too much into the weekend
then we've got Columbus Day and
Indigenous people's day on Monday and
ever so slowly the temperatures will
slide into the upper 80s some clouds
around on Tuesday doesn't look like it's
going to be as windy next week as we
first thought but there will be some
clouds and cooler mid 80s with Mornings
in the 60s all right let's check the
drive all right Sherry so the freeways
are really in excellent shape when we're
talking about being here on coming up on
6 30 on a Finally Friday North 215
Beltway West 215 Beltway even the
southern 215 Beltway now of course it's
all going to jam up a little bit more as
we get closer to oh say 6 30 or 7 but
the only trouble spot if you want to
call it that is the I-15 Southbound just
a bunch of cars on the road now we do
see a couple of cars off on the left
shoulder on the Northbound side sorry
the camera is getting a little bit fuzzy
on you there but this is the southbound
side North on a couple of cars off on
the left shoulder with the central
Resort quarter up there on the right
hand side we promised you a look at
Spring Mountain and Las Vegas Boulevard
that's actually even gotten better than
it was when we started this morning of
course the inner section completely shut
down under police investigation
yesterday they even shut down the exits
from the 15 to Spring Mountain all back
open and even a couple of hours ago
there were a bunch of construction cones
and still some turning delays but they
moved all the cones off to the side so
Spring Mountain Las Vegas Boulevard
doing much better so Sherry stirring up
some hot chocolate for you that's coming
up next
it sure is yeah you don't want to go
anywhere because it's going to get sweet
maybe a little spicy hot chocolate is
here she is talking about her career all
the festivities for Las Vegas Pride
weekend we're kicking it off right here
next on Good Day Las Vegas
[Music]